you know they increased all the little
things that you would expect for them to
increase like I remember uh if they have
no problem overwhelming you with zombies
like there's a lot of incidences in this
game where they're like just run don't
try to fight them there's too many of
them uh so they put these things in here
like you know there's like these water
cans that you can put water everywhere
and then you have like the uh what we
used to do is I would put the water
everywhere and smooth would have like
the electric baton and he would just
start hitting the water lightning
everyone and you see the lightning
reaching up and just hitting the zombies
and keeping them in place like
that's what's up funny so did I was
looking at a larger gaming uh review
shot that I mean uh